Spiderman watch
out
misery misery misery that's what you've
chosen I offered you
friendship and you spat in my
face
[Music]
stop
you've spun your last web
Spider-man had you not been so selfish
your little girlfriend's death would
have been quick and painless but now I'm
going to finish her nice and
slow MJ and
I we're going to have an interesting
time
[Music]
where is she oh she'll be just fine
let's
talk
H
[Music]
nice
what the
[Music]
hell
I think
know I think
[Music]
s
a
[Music]
yeah
h
you have a train to
[Music]
catch
Flint
Marco what do you want from me remember
Ben
Parker the old man you shot down in Cold
Blood what do it matter to you
[Music]
anyway
everything
[Music]
it's time to pay
Marco
[Music]
a
go
[Music]
good
riddance never
wound what you can't
kill Eddie the
suit you got to take it off oh youd like
that wouldn't
you I know what it feels like it feels
good the power everything but you'll
lose
yourself Let It
Go I like being
bad it makes me
happy
[Applause]
[Music]
what
[Applause]
[Music]
hurry
[Applause]
ah a
[Music]
[Applause]
Peter what are you
doing
no
go
[Music]
nowhere to hide
Peter
[Music]
all these Souls lost and alone I can
save them I can cure them there's no
need to stop me
[Music]
Peter
not thinking straight
doc stop this this isn't
you let's talk this
out oh
boy all right so you don't want to talk
there you
go
don't make me have to hurt
you that is
disgusting
I'm going to throw you out the window
now
go
[Music]
yeah
60 seconds to
[Applause]
[Music]
impact
now what now do it
[Music]
now
687 this lagia Tower turn immediately to
heading
280 you have incoming traffic I repeat
280 defend
immediately
[Applause]
all right people back to work let's land
these planes I'll be
back thank God all right all right we're
back everyone let's
go Peter
when you said Spider-Man said
no you meant you said no Harry what did
you do what you made me
do you were my friend and you betrayed
me no I was trying to protect
you look at me hey it's going to be okay
this is going to be all right you don't
give people home you take get away no
Harry I'm going to take away yours no
run run
Harry Harry put her
down Harry stop this right now this
isn't you Harry this is this is not you
Harry put her down Harry Harry is dead
Harry this is between you and me you
want to fight fight me let her
go
okay
[Music]
no
you're I got you qu I'm going to put you
down right here
ah
[Music]
stop
a
I'll take
those hey guys the illegal weapons deal
fa was at 10:30 you missed
it spider guys
here wo whoo wo wo wo not so
fast are you guys okay my bad that was a
hard I got to say the other guy was way
better with that
thing I'm honestly I'm I'm
shocked freeze
FBI get on the ground FBI wait what do
you mean FBI the FBI is the Federal
Bureau of inv the FBI means but what are
they doing here
[Music]
out of the way get out of the
way get
out look out look out look out move move
move get to the top deck we're getting
out of
here
a
that's Taser
[Music]
work you're messing with things you
don't
understand
help
oh my God what do I do Karen uh give me
an x-ray to the boat and Target all the
strong strongest
points wiip grenade wiip
grenade whip
go
great job Peter you're 98% successful 98
yeah
[Applause]
Spiderman no no
no
[Music]
what the
hell
your lies are over
be this certainly isn't ideal but I have
contingencies
Edith just give me the
glasses you want
these come and get
him
come on Peter
tingle
why aren't these drones firing you're in
the strike zone the chance of getting
hit is fire all the drones
[Music]
now
back
be you lied to me and I trusted you I
know that the
most disappointing
part you're a good person
Peter such a
weakness it's dark was
right you do deserve
that
[Music]
you can't trick me
anymore Edith turn off the
drones biometric scan complete welcome
back Peter shall I execute all
cancellation protocols do it execute
them all
confirmed
get
out strong enough to have it
all too weak to take
it
h now I got
you I told you there'd be
[Music]
consequences your weakness Peter is
morality it's choking you
can't you feel
it it didn't
work Norman was right he got it from you
that
pathetic
sickness you tried to fix me m now I'm
going to fix
you
M Run
[Music]
please
okay
Spider-Man damman
first I'm going to lead him inside the
Statue I'll meet you at the
top come on
hey hey Dr Connors hello
Peter Peter what I got
[Music]
it
a blit we're trying to help
you guys I'm at the top I need to
cure I'm coming I'm coming I'm
coming just wait you're turn do I'll be
right
back
[Music]
yeah
it's okay
Flint we're going to get you
home we just stay right
[Music]
here how do we stop him I've never seen
him this powerful it's the ark reactor
we got to get it off him you not have to
take this away from
me that's not going to
work
okay we got to do this up close Peter 2
go right Peter 3 go left on
me
[Music]
um I don't
know not working all right it's fine
you're going to do it again you're just
going to keep trying Focus close the
portal close the
portal oh no no no no and that is a
lizard and we
should
run
Conor
[Music]
stop
yeah leave them they're mine I don't
need your help I got just fine Dr davius
no what are you
doing get it off of
[Music]
[Applause]
me there you
go
[Music]
MJ Spider-Man oh hey didn't see you
there okay I'm I'm kind of freaking out
right now I mean you're supposed to be
dead surprise oh okay that's that that's
a no no we don't like that this is
fascinating okay that's my face entirely
different Peter Parker okay A little bit
of a gut perhaps from dimensional
warping oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I was way
flatter before I
warped what was the rest
deterioration hey how old are you cuz
you don't look a day over 35
was
crazy you show him you're not crazy this
might pinch a
little ow no I just need to get these
samples okay organize your desktop lady
wow just complete cellular
Decay never seen anything like this what
are you doing I'm just taking the whole
thing and obviously you've been
glitching glitching no why would you
even say that you stay in this
dimmension too too long your body's
going to disintegrate do you know how
painful that would be Peter Parker I
don't know you can't
imagine and I for one can't wait to
watch what did you say your name was Dr
Olivia
Octavius can I assume that your friends
call you doc my friends actually call me
live my enemies call me doca I got this
run
[Music]
k no sorry that's
cheating
I got to get to
[Music]
thato not so easy doing it on your own
isn't
it I can't wait to kill one more
Spiderman I what
wison is this what you want man what are
you doing please stay away froma what's
wrong with you Messa Richard what are we
doing here I don't know Richard Messa
it's me you know me we're leaving now
don't
no stay with me
please you're not staring not today I am
stopping this right
now
I need back
up
[Music]
the real Spiderman couldn't even beat
me you're not
you took my
family now I'm going to make sure you'll
never see yours
again hey Spider-Man off Mor I mean
this is not what it looks like hey hey
my kid go here man this is I'm on the
PTA you know how many limit bars I got
to make for that he left in the middle
of a fight I did not it was actually are
you serious it was inconsiderate and
super rude and a little cocky yeah you
got me agre with the bad guy right now
bad guy he's barely a villain of the
weak what' you call me you realize I'm
right on man
everything is under
control
unbelievable of course we'd end up back
here you know what you are just like my
son I am I that's so silly how imagine
that back where it all
started The Crucible of our
connection hey don't try to wow me with
big
words is it all coming back to you
talking about the creation
events
what okay we got cut off this is our
talking about nothing is more important
than
family yeah I'm kind of in the middle of
something Destiny brought us here you
see now don't you I I really don't I am
your Nemesis you are not
you missed you can't contain the St now
you really don't remember what you did
to me what I did for you uh no I worked
at Alx I ran a test on this collider
that brought a spider here from another
dimension 42 it's home Dimension it
escaped and it bit
you my spider made you
Spider-Man what you ran through the
cafeteria you hit me with a
bagel I've hit a lot of different
villains with a lot of different food
make your flippy little sassy jokes
everyone loves them but no one knows
what it feels like to be on the other
side of them I'm just trying to lighten
the mood I created you you created me
Spider-Man why did you create that guy I
didn't he's talking crazy I was in this
collider room when you blew it
up
[Music]
because of
you I lost my job my life my face my
family won't even look at me I made you
into a hero you meet me into this look
at me you did this to me look at me I'll
make you respect
me I am your
what where'd he go he kicked his own
butt what are those claws dude are you
sure you're even
Spider-Man are you who do you think you
are
really my name is Miles
[Music]
Morales I was bitten by a radio this
spider I'm pretty sure you know the rest
[Music]
jerk what's up
man you don't get it you're in the noal
not if you let me go
home
snitch everywhere you you go you're an
anomaly you're the original
anomaly the spider that gave you your
powers wasn't from your
dimension it was never supposed to fight
you there's a world out there with no
Spider-Man to protect them because
because it been you instead you're not
supposed to be Spider-Man no you're
lying I'm Spider-Man you're a
mistake if you hadn't been bit your
Peter Parker would have lived instead he
died saving you he would have stopped
the collider before it ever went off
spot wouldn't exist and none of this
would have happened and all this time I
have been the only one holding it all
together go easy on you don't belong
here you never did
let that's enough this isn't what we
talked
about you talked about
this you
knew you you all
knew I I didn't
know how to tell
you that's why you never came to see
me miles it's for your own good who
decides that I'm not a kid
gwy that's exactly what you are you're
just a kid has no idea what he's
doing yeah well I did lure hundreds of
spider people away from your little
clubhouse I guess you did plan this
out and I'm about to do
[Music]
this everyone keeps telling me how my
story is supposed to
go nah I'mma do my own
[Music]
thing